we begin our coverage tonight with one
of the most important parts of in-person
learning
public school transportation as children
will be crossing streets and taking the
bus
there will be a lot more activity on our
roadways madison kimbrough joins us
tonight with the latest on district
plans to keep our bus systems moving
safely
for drivers and students madison yes our
public school transportation system is
going to look a lot different this year
with major guidelines put in place for
students and staff
to follow it's been over a year
since we've had students on our roads on
our sidewalks
so this is really going to be really
going to require some change in
behaviors and attitudes while many are
focused on the return of face-to-face
learning
and the safety that goes along with it
another major topic to consider is our
school's bus
transportation system we will be
operating 1600 bus routes
across the valley public school
transportation is going to look a lot
different now
buses will only run at half capacity and
that's about 28 students on board
students will be spaced out while riding
drivers will load the bus
from the back to the front and unload
from the front to the back
each student will sit in the next
available seat and follow
seat markings to ensure that our kids
are practicing social distancing
while on the buses unlike before school
zones will now be active
so it's important for drivers to slow
down and for walkers to be vigilant of
their surroundings
if children are present if the lights
are on or 30 minutes before or after
school those are all indicators that it
is an active school zone
and for students that means keeping your
head up while walking
and not looking down at your phone and
buses will also be thoroughly cleaned
after each use and face coverings are
required
hand sanitizer will be provided for
students and drivers as they get on and
off the bus
reporting in the studio madison
kimbrough 8 news now